let's go get the [ __ ] out of us my love
[Applause]
[Music]
so merry Christmas to all who celebrate
and those who don't hope you have a nice
day regardless I am going to take this
opportunity to talk about my favorite
Christmas movie I watch it every single
year I actually I still watch it with my
daughter's mother even though we are not
together because we I get together on
Christmas Eve to set up the Christmas
for the following morning and we watch
Love Actually Love Actually is one of my
favorite movies of all time it's my
favorite Christmas movie it's my
favorite or romantic comedy I adore this
movie so I would think people know what
Love Actually is by now but on the
off-chance you don't it is a British
romantic comedy with I don't even know
how many a lot of overlapping
intersecting parallel stories about
various people couples relationships
relationships having problems
relationships beginning relationships
having problems beginning relationships
possibly ending all during the lead-up
to Christmas and it cuts between all of
these we get eventually connections
between some of them and that's just it
you've got a whole bunch of stuff going
on you have this newly married couple
and the best man who you know seems to
just sort of not be on board with this
entire pairing you've got a woman who's
got a crush on a guy at her work
basically ever since she's been there
you have a married man who is being
tempted by a new person in his office
being tempted to cheat you have someone
who just lost his wife you have a young
kid who has his first crush you've got
the Prime Minister of Britain who just
got elected into office and is finding
himself against his better judgment
romantically interested with someone on
his staff you have an aging rocker
trying to have his new song be the new
Christmas number one and if that's the
one sounds weird like it's the odd one
out because there's no relationship
elements stick with it it gets there and
like you've got a writer who goes off -
I think it's France you know - right as
he always does and there is a
housekeeper that he has and despite the
fact that neither of them speak the
other's language they begin falling for
each other and I'm probably even oh yeah
there's a guy who makes the decision
that he's got to go to America because
the reason he can't get a girlfriend is
because American girls are cooler and
they would dig his accent and he is
convinced that once he gets there he
will be swarmed with women so he's he's
off on his mission I think I've covered
everything I might have missed one or
two but yeah there's a lot going on and
for all of that it really is
phenomenally construct that is the
ultimate key to this it is really well
constructed in the point at which it
transitions from story to story to story
all feels thematic things build and in
sync with each other to a glorious
climactic stretch of the film where
multiple of these stories hit their
climactic points all together and it
really is amazing now unfortunately we
do have to kind of blame this movie for
the rush of holiday-themed
some films in this structure like
Valentine's Day and New Year's Day and
just all these just junk that thought Oh
we'll do that formula not realizing it's
not about a bunch of stories set at
Christmas it's about how these things
are different elements of how
relationships work and how they move
forward and how love you know keeps the
world moving basically it and it's again
it's just phenomenally constructed and a
big part of why I love this movie is
look I need to be blunt about something
I do not like many romantic comedies
there's very very very few of them I can
kind of even like tolerate
and ultimately what kills a lot of
romantic comedies for me is that I hate
the kinds of stuff that that genre tends
to use as filler because our romantic
comedy generally breaks down in a very
simple structure here's the two people
who are going to end up together by the
by the end of the film and then we're
gonna spend an hour and a half to two
hours throwing obstacles in the way of
that happening and that tends to result
in you know extended humiliation humor
sequences a lot of the time a lot of you
know lunches with caddy friends a lot of
women just don't understand how men
think or vice versa like in the all
those sorts of scenes jammed in to fill
the gaps in order to delay the couple
that we know is gonna get together
ultimately getting a misunderstandings
that's a huge one somebody always
misunderstands or miss hears or miss
interprets this that or the other I just
and ie some of those things I don't like
inherently others I'm just friggin sick
of but what's brilliant about this movie
is because it's all these stories laying
over each other all the fillers gone
this is legitimately there's probably
about six complete romantic comedies in
here that could be their own movie if
you stuck all the filler back in and I
probably wouldn't like any of them but
what is removed in order to have all
these stories in a single film is all
the filler the filler is gone and
although is left are the scenes that
actually move things forward the scenes
that actually connect you with these
characters the scenes that matter that's
what's left the best parts not the crap
that you you know you go and you get a
snack during that's all gone and what's
left is amazing and this cast holy crap
this cast alright I'm not even sure I
can even remember everybody in this but
you've got people who are already big at
the time and then people who have become
big since then so you know you're
running the gamut from Colin Firth Hugh
Grant Bill Nighy Liam Neeson I'm
sin' keira knightley Chiwetel Ejiofor
Laura Lenny
I just oh my ah I've lost his name a lot
of the guys the main guy on walking dead
now he's in this it's it is a terrific
cast and everybody's great in it all the
people I mentioned of Alan Rickman got
how could i how could I forget to
mention Alan Rickman all these people
are amazing and even the people who you
don't who if you don't watch a ton of
British shows you wouldn't know
otherwise they're all great like
everybody's great whether they're in one
scene or five Rowan Atkinson has two
appearances he's great like everyone is
phenomenal in this I love the range and
the scope of the stories ultimately
since this is about this is a movie
about the the uplifting power of love
most of these end well but there's a
handful of them that that end more
melancholy or just it just doesn't work
or end in a way that is kind of
bittersweet and then there's the ones
that end like perfectly and it's just a
glorious balance of these things and
because you do have those more the the
sadder ones the ones that end a little
bit less fulfilling Lee that are more
bittersweet or more melancholy that
helps it that helps keep it from being
the overly saccharine film that it
easily could have been and again is
another thing that I think works in is
benefit given a lot of the tropes of
romantic comedies because usually in
romantic comedies you know your your
your second act you know where
everything goes to crap right before it
comes together ends up being really
contrived that's where a lot of stuff
that I talked about about
miscommunications come in and that but
because this has some stories that just
flat-out don't end in the way that would
be ideal for these characters you don't
have to do this hard pull down on the
ones that are on a nicer trajectory they
still have complications in those but
like the the the counterbalance often
exists in other stories entirely and
just the construction of this thing the
tightness of it I love it I love it to
absolute death I know there are some
criticisms that I've seen of it I know
some people are I'm not sure it's a
criticism but it's a it's it's a little
bit regretful that there isn't that out
all of the couples in this are sis
hetero couples there was actually a
lesbian couple in the film in an earlier
cut that got trimmed not because of
anything wrong with it but because
basically the whole subplot that that
factored into wasn't great and was kind
of bogging down the movie so it got
excised with this whole sort of subplot
and unfortunately you know it was a
relationship that didn't have a
connection and it stand on its own is
something that fit without the context
of that subplot that got cut so that is
that is kind of unfortunate so like
maybe my ideal movie one of these would
be a queer couple but the fact that they
aren't doesn't make it a bad movie and I
appreciate the fact that it was the
intention to have that but ultimately
when you're cutting and you're editing
especially something as potentially you
know labyrinthine and over complicated
as this you you need to make the
decision that's gonna make for the best
film that's gonna be the best story
structure that's gonna have this the
smoothest execution of the idea and
sometimes you lose good stuff when you
do that but like I personally have no
complaints about this I love every joke
I love it like Bill Nighy cracks me up
every single time and you know there are
other things it's it's funny which of
these stories I find myself relating to
the most it changes with time as I get
older I'm not gonna say which ones I
gotta relate more to now which ones I
used to relate to more before because
that's like getting a little too much
into like my personal life but it's it's
an interesting thing to go back and
revisit every year which I and I do
every single year I get to revisit this
and see what moves me this time and so
it often
time's it something else will hit me a
little bit harder than it did the last
year and maybe something that you know
was you know oh right in the fields it's
a little bit softer this time or but the
things that are funny are always funny
and I oh this movie always ends and I
just feel good and that's me rambling
about why Love Actually is my favorite
Christmas film it's my favorite romantic
comedy it's one of my favorite films
which is amazing considering romantic
comedy is a genre I actively avoid so
those are my thoughts on Love Actually
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down to comments let's talk
about it whole bunch of stuff you can do
because there's buttons and there's
links including one to my patreon if you
feel like being generous tis the season
maybe that's a bit exploitive I should
cut that I won't because I'm lazy and
until next time this counsel
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]